hi folks welcome you're logged into the
second of 12 Barry soil and nutrient
management webinars sponsored by
northeast sustainable research and
education program and hosted by Cornell
University Department of Horticulture
and Cornell Cooperative Extension my
name is Jeff Miller Colin calling you
right now from oneida county central new
york and i'll be your moderator for this
webinar will be starting promptly at two
p.m. eastern standard time I do want to
direct you to the pieces of what you're
viewing right now off to the left is the
list of attendees and you can see from
the comments and the chat box in a
lower-middle that there are people from
Penn State joining us UMass people from
New York State so we got a good
collection of people joining us today
and if you look to the lower left you'll
see a series of web links one is soil
nutrient management webinar so that's
where you'll find a lot of information
about what's being present today and in
future events and below it is
publication building soils for better
crops and then I'll direct you to the
far right where there's a file box and
if you haven't joined us before this is
a second meeting if you would download
the demographics and the educator
pre-tests at your leisure you can do
that after this program today and if you
would fill them out and then send them
in to Kathy Hutton Rick and she's her
addresses on those pieces and send them
in to her that would be very helpful to
fulfill our requirements for the grants
and we're going to take questions
throughout the program but we're going
to answer the questions at the end so
with that I'm going to switch over and
introduce our speaker for today
our speaker is Harold vanness he's
professor of soil and water management
chair of the Department of crop and soil
Sciences at Cornell University this
current research and extension interests
are in precision management of nitrogen
soil health and space time statistics
Harold teaches an undergrad undergrad
course in soil management for
sustainability and a grad course in
space-time statistics he's going to talk
to us today about soil types accessing
soil surveys and soil physical chemical
and biological properties and with that
I'm going to turn over to Harold good
day everyone I hope you can hear me um
beautiful day here in Ithaca and I see a
lot of familiar names here on the
participant list so I say hi to all of
you it's a it's a it's a pleasure to be
able to present this through this format
so today it this will be more of an
introductory webinar as it relates to to
bury production and in the more
subsequent webinars we're going to be
talking more about sort of management
approaches so today will be what more
conceptual and we'll talk more about the
about the principles so quick outline
for today we'll start out with
discussion on Cyril health concepts will
discuss the concept of inherent soil
quality and the use of soil survey
information and then we'll discuss each
of the three realms of soil health the
chemical characteristics and
measurements the physical and then the
biological and with the biological we'll
also talk quite a bit about the role of
organic matter which is a key component
and then towards the end I'll just have
a few slides about management
considerations for for Barry production
basically as an introduction to to the
subsequent webinars so many of you I
think are probably familiar with this
concept but you know I'd like to
refer to soil health as the capacity of
the Searle to function and you can think
of a much larger definition but it's all
about you know how to serve functions
we're all familiar with the concept of
human health and and how we as humans
function and similarly we think about
soils functioning in the context of this
discussion of course that the primary
function is for that soil is to to
produce a good crop both high quality
and high high quantities so what what
are characteristics of a healthy soil in
the same way we think of a healthy human
being as having you know blood pressure
in a certain range you know 80 over you
know 120 over 80 a heartbeat at a
certain rate a cholesterol level at a
certain rate so in terms of healthy
Searles we can think of all all of these
this is certainly not an exhaustive
exhaustive list so sufficient amount of
nutrients but not excess because that
can create problems environmentally or
or economically as well in some cases
good tills sufficient depth for good
rooting good water storage and drainage
to get it through dry and wet periods
free of harmful chemicals low
populations of plant disease and
parasitic organisms and vice vice versa
higher populations of beneficial
organisms low blood pressure resistance
to being degraded to say through
compaction or erosion and a resilient
soil that recovers quickly from adverse
events like like excess water hurricane
or something like that
so what's what's important to sort of
understand it is our soil health
philosophy that we that we think in
terms of the the three major realms the
physical the chemical and the biological
and and the whole point is that a
healthy soil is balanced in that respect
and therefore provides for good growing
conditions and resiliency and and also
reduced inputs in general over the past
decades we've we've tended to
overemphasize the the chemical aspect of
the soil we've and and and and not to a
fault necessarily but we've developed
good testing procedures I think most
farmers and growers know how to how to
use and manage the the chemistry of the
soil the the physical aspects and
especially a biological aspect we
haven't really paid nearly as much
attention to and yet these are also very
important component of the functioning
of the soil so during this this webinar
I'm going to pay a little bit more
attention to the physical and the
biological components so when we think
in terms of the functioning of the soil
we can sort of parse that down to a
processes so on this slide we we have
the three realms the physical biological
and chemical and and to the site there
you see the different processes that are
critical for a soil to function well for
example physical support is a physical
function aeration is a physical process
water storage and movement resistance to
erosion root proliferation and organism
will those are all physical processes
that that are affected by things like
compaction and an aggregate stability on
the chemical realm the one that we're
typically a little bit more familiar
with nutrient storage and release so
reaction which relates mostly to ph
carbon storage and energy which is that
the important role of organic matter
that we'll discuss later and then we
have all those important biological
functions
suppressing pests and vice versa having
beneficial organisms nitrogen
mineralization organic matter
decomposition and supporting microbial
communities so we have these these three
realms they do interact and we'll talk
about that a little bit later and but
it's important that we think in terms of
the processes because if any of these
processes is compromised for example if
you have for aeration and there's a lot
of other problems that result from that
for example more more disease problems
of nutrient deficiencies and all those
kind of things so it's important that we
think in terms of processes another
concept that we need to keep in mind is
is that of inherent versus dynamic soil
quality and that not all soils are the
same that way what do we mean with
inherent sore quality it's basically the
idea that soils are created differently
that some soils are you know sandy
others are maybe silt loam and yet
others or clay loams and this is really
the result of all these kind of natural
genetic soil forming processes some
searles are naturally well drained
others are not someone naturally high in
organic matter other or not so this is
sort of the basic soil quality that is
often also represented in the soil
survey information the dynamics or
quality on the other hand relates more
to how how the soil has developed as a
result of management and we can think of
that in terms of both negative and
positive directions so a very high
quality soil may become very degraded
due to erosion or compaction or a lot of
intensive till it's over over many years
and so it maybe become a less desirable
and less well-functioning soil on the
other hand you can improve the soil as
well you can take us or L that's that's
a low and organic matter content and
over a period of five or six years you
can build that up to become a much more
high quality soil
when we when we talk about soil health
we primarily refer to this dynamics or
equality so that the part of the sorc
walla tea that we can influence by
management the other component the
inherence or quality is more more or
less a given you know you can't
necessarily change that so again the
inherence or quality the results of some
of these long-term geologic biotic
climatic and topographic factors so this
blueberry field here is located in kind
of a valley environment with certain
soil types it may be gravely or sandy
soil as you often find in the Northeast
but the soil say on this hillside would
be would be very different they would
have by different depth different
organic matter content different drain
it's more susceptible to erosion etc so
typically that the first thing that you
want to do is select a site that has
favorable soil conditions and you can do
that by using soil survey information
the site selection I would say is is
it's critical to successful berry
management if you start out with a soil
that's inherently of low quality you're
just basically have an uphill battle
it's difficult to overcome a lot of
those constraints so what are some of
those inherent primary properties and I
think most of you are familiar with that
in terms of the physical ones sorrel
texture of course is very very critical
whether you have a sand silt clay or
anything in between what do you have a
lot of stones and that that often sort
of sets you know a lot of the other
important soil properties whether you
have a problem with internal drainage or
not you can modify that if you have a
drainage problem and you probably want
to install some drainage the depth of
the soil or presence of barriers for
example a fragile pan can sometimes be
modified but maybe a major constraint
and then slope can also be an issue
in terms of the chemistry we have come
back to that we have a number of
nutrients that we're concerned about pH
is very important and even though a lot
of these can be corrected and modified
it's typically you know if you start out
with a soil for example that's very
acidic it's it's often difficult to
overcome but another important point to
make of course is that especially with
dairy production that certain crops
favor a lower pH like blueberries and
others do not and so that's all
something that you have to keep in mind
salt accumulation is not as much of a
concern here in Northeast but in other
parts of the country or the world that
can be a major constraint very difficult
to to overcome and then we have a number
of course biological components and
typically in terms of the basic primary
properties that is expressed to the
organic matter content in the soil if
you have higher organic matter levels
typically that soil is healthier it can
support a lot more diverse and and
intensive biological processes and we'll
talk about that in a few minutes so much
of that basic information on these
primary properties can be gathered from
Cyril survey reports this is a selection
of soil surveys from the state of New
York some of them are are quite old the
early ones are from the 1930s and then
the most recent ones are from the 1990s
I think maybe even from century they
provide you with all that basic
information about texture pH available
water capacity etc it tells you whether
what the suitability for use of any of
those soils is is it is it good farmland
what are some of the constraints for
example but keep in mind that within
sight variability may be a factor these
soils have been mapped by cyril
surveyors but typically the level of
detail that's that needs to be
considered for
establishment of an orchard or a very
production field it is not quite
sufficient but it's a it's a very good
early start these publications are
available from extension office's for
from certain water conservation district
offices and Natural Resources
Conservation districts and and several
other places often libraries have them
as well but i wanted to point out that a
lot of this information now is available
also through the web through the web
soil survey site here's the the website
actually if you just google web soil
survey you will get there and it allows
you to basically access soil survey
information for any location in the
country what you would do is you would
start by pressing this virtual button
here that says start web soil survey
then you would get to through various
screens you would get to something like
this let's say we're interested in
establishing some very production on a
field that we have perhaps like here and
then we can get a lot of basic
information about that soil from this
web soil survey site so on the left here
you see this area is an Ontario loam two
to eight percent slope gives us
information on some basic climate
logical information the geomorphological
setting of the soil and some very basic
properties then we can get more
information for for this soil and that's
listed here on on the left the basic
chemical properties calcium carbonate
content cation exchange capacity pH
gypsum level etc now keep in mind that
this is sort of the expected chemical
properties is not actually from this
field it tends to be from another Cyril
profile that is representative of that
field and it may have been changed the
previous user may have changed a pH by
line
or the sodium absorption ratio may have
been changed so those are all things
that that at least you know provide a
starting point we see a lot of physical
properties they tend to be more
consistent available water capacity of
bulk density although that may have
changed to the compaction organic matter
content texture etc so there's a lot of
basic information also including water
table information that is an excellent
starting point that you can access
directly from the web now so that's that
basically relates to the inherent soil
properties but we typically want to get
some more detailed information not only
what for it to be a more site-specific
so actually Cyril samples that were
collected from that particular field
where we're considering to establish
varies but also more detailed
information on the physical the
biological and the chemical components
of the soil and that's what the soil
health testing for the Cornell's oral
health test basically attempts to do
we've selected for physical indicators
and physical in our cases always
indicated with the letter blue or the
color blue biological indicators also
for indicated in green and then the
yellow the chemical indicators the the
soil health test which we'll come back
to in later webinars of it basically
uses the standard Cyril nutrient
analysis and then has enhanced it with
for biological indicators organic matter
active carbon potentially analyzable
nitrogen and a root health rating and
then these four physical indicators
aggregate stability available water
capacity and hardness of the soil and
the surface and subsurface and then the
test identifies constraints and that
then allows you to take some management
actions to overcome those constraints
this is just a basic introduction to
that but one of the main points is that
you know the inherent so equality can be
gathered from the soil survey
information but the more dynamic soil
quality or sort of health you want to
get from from some more site specific
information like through a soil health
test okay so let's talk a lot about
chemical processes most of you I think
are that's the area that you're more
familiar with there are a number of
essential nutrients for plants the left
we have the large then once that are
needed in larger amounts or macro
nutrients including carbon oxygen
hydrogen which are basically around from
the air and water in the soil and then
we have the NPK nitrogen phosphorus
potassium calcium and magnesium and
sulfur that are needed in larger
quantities and any of these may be
limiting at any time on the right we
have them the micronutrients iron
manganese etc and these are used in
relatively small quantities the the
fortunate part is that recommendations
have been developed over the past
decades for the management of all of
these nutrients typically what it
requires is a basic soil test and
recommendations come with that and it's
a fairly straightforward situation it's
typically relatively easy to correct any
of these deficiencies through the use of
fertilizer a pH tends to be a little bit
more tricky in in that very plants favor
different ph environments but also the
availability of various nutrients is
impacted by pH so on the right here we
have a scale from the age of four and a
half 28 and we see that different
nutrients nitrates potassium etc are
available in the more or less available
in different ph ranges for example
phosphates or phosphorus is not very
available either
a high pH or low pH calcium is is very
available at higher pH but not at the
low pH where we may have a lot of
aluminum available in fact it may become
toxic iron very available at low PH but
not very available at high ph so etc so
so pH is actually a very critical
component and and the reason why I
wanted to discuss this separately is is
that from the perspective of
establishing varies you need to address
this upfront you got to get to ph right
from the start and before you establish
the plants you have your your best
opportunity to correct any potential pH
problems again the soil test will
provide you with the recommendations um
another concept that we often talk about
and those of you have taken a soil
fertility class are familiar with this
is it so called liebig's law of the
minimum the idea is that that your yield
or the ability of the of the plant to be
productive is limited by the most
limiting nutrient so and it's
represented by this this bucket here in
our case nitrogen is the most limiting
nutrient and so the yield potential is
limited by the amount of nation soil
this is here depicted by the water
overflow and you can't get more water in
the bucket than the lowest level and the
most limiting nutrient and so this is
this is generally generally true but
there is basically a broader perspective
that we now come to appreciate in the
context of soil health and that's
basically that it's not all about the
soil chemistry that it may actually be a
physical or maybe a biological process
that is is the most limiting factor in
in the production so it's it's not only
what's the most limiting chemical
element but it's all it's more what's
limiting otherwise so you may for
example have a very compacted soil
and maybe plenty of nutrients and you
may have actually applied a lot of these
these nutrients through fertilizer but
the fact that the soil is compacted that
the roots aren't growing well or that
you have aeration problems is is then or
has become the most limiting element
um Janet Fallon next week we'll be
talking about Cyril testing and I won't
go into a lot of detail but an
interesting point to keep in mind is
that that's the soil test is basically
an extraction procedure you you
basically extract some of the elements
through a solution out of the soil
that's being filtered and then analyzed
with various equipment for example like
an ICP or something like that what's
what's important to keep in mind is that
there are many different Cyril test
solutions that are being used around the
country even within the Northeast we
have quite a few different ones being
used you know for example male III and
Morgan and modified Morgan are being
used around the Northeast it's important
to make a distinction because the
interpretation of the soil test results
and in this case for example it's for
phosphorus varies based on the type of
extraction that you use some of them are
more aggressive extractants or they're
done in a different ph and so you
interpret the numbers differently okay
so for example in a Morgan analysis the
optimum range is about for phosphorus is
about four to seven while the equivalent
form a league three is fifteen to thirty
one so you need to basically tie your
cert test results to the actual
methodology that was used in the testing
procedure and unfortunately for better
or worse we're using a lot of different
procedures around the region and around
the country especially so keep that in
mind when you think about soil testing
okay let's move on to the physical
aspects of the soil the one of the big
factors especially here in the Northeast
at that can you know limit the ability
of healthy plant is poor internal
drainage it can be the result of either
of local Cyril hydrology because it's
kind of in a low spot in the landscape
it can also be because of impeding
soil layers he may have said dense layer
or a fragile pen at limits the
percolation of the water through the
soil and thereby causes poor drainage
it's a big problem poor drainage means
for aeration it tends to exacerbate
disease problems and all that and and if
you are having are you considering a
field that has poor internal drainage
either me may want to move to a
different field or you make sure that
you identify or that you that you
correct that problem to do the
installation of drainage it is
identifying from Cyril survey
publications I showed that in one of the
previous slides but i also would always
suggest because the soil survey
publication is just a kind of a first
approximation to also do some on sites
or like excavations if you see modeling
or you know launches of iron rust or
manganese which is which is black
blotches if you see that in a subsoil
you typically have a problem with a
fluctuating water table and therefore
you have imperfect drainage this will be
a theme that I'll be coming back to a
lot of times we ignore what's happening
deeper in the soil we tend to focus on
on the service oil but poor drainage is
often expressed a little bit deeper in
the soil and so make sure you pay
attention to that you can of course
remediate poor internal drainage by
installing drain lines but also raised
beds as you can see here on the on the
right now these are actually tomatoes
but I would I was just with almost any
type of very production that you want to
use raised beds and one of the reasons
certainly is to improve the drainage or
at least during very wet periods it
keeps the keeps the roots of the of your
berries under aerobic conditions and you
prevent some of those problems I'll keep
in mind that in some cases a poor
drainage is not necessarily related to
soil layers or local
so hydrology but it can be a symptom of
compaction so if you see a lot of water
sitting on the sorrel service that may
be because the soil has become very
degraded and compacted in it and the
water doesn't move and infiltrate
through the soil which is then a problem
that you need to separately address
installing tile drains doesn't
necessarily solve the problem you need
to address that through the organic
matter additions or putting in a cover
crop or something like that
okay so I always liked it when I talk
about the physical properties of soils
I'd like to discuss the importance of
aggregates and here is a picture of a
large aggregate that's a part of this
size and as you can see that I regret is
made up actually of three sub aggregates
okay as you can see here and each of
those three are then in turn made up of
other sub aggregates ok so there's
typically a hierarchical system in a
well aggregated soil and if you
especially have a finer texture like it
like a silt or clay loam and this
aggregation is very important because it
creates larger pores while also
maintaining these smaller pores larger
pores are important for drainage and
aeration and for root development small
pores on the other hand are important
for moisture retention and then we want
some intermediate pores as well so that
we basically have a range also important
for water retention lot of the
biological functions are the organisms
dwell in these intermediate course so
what we'd like to see with a good soil
is this range of pores from large to
intermediate too small well what happens
when a soil becomes compacted you mostly
lose in that case these large pores and
so what problems do you then get well
you get problems with drainage get
problems with aeration and root
proliferation becomes ok so so
compaction basically creates a lot of
problems that in turn can create other
problems like higher disease pressure
etc okay a little bit about water
availability to to plants you know most
of you I think are familiar with the
idea of you know soil that's it has poor
plant water available like like a beach
sand because it only has large large
pores it doesn't
have any small pores on the other hand
you may have a clay loam that has a lot
of lot of small portion so that has much
better ability to retain water so it is
a function of texture organic matter
content however is also a very important
component of this because organic matter
can really act as a sponge thirdly
rooting depth is important if you have
roots that are constrained say to only
the top six inches then they won't be
able to access the water and the
nutrients that are deeper in the soil so
compaction is a is a big problem in that
respect it reduces both root
proliferation and water access by the
plants but we can improve that and we'll
talk about that later in the course we
can use things like deep ripping as you
see here does it say strip till a piece
of equipment we can add compost for
example to improve structure any
aggregation and the routing there are
ways to to address that for soils in in
our climates are often associated with
with good drainage so like a gravelly
loam or or loamy sand or something like
that and they tend to then have problems
with with water stress in most cases
that's that's not desirable only I think
if you're growing grapes you often want
a little bit of water stress but for
most berries it's not very desirable and
that means that you may have to invest
in irrigation there's some very good
irrigation systems available now and a
lot of that requires some upfront
considerations so thinking ahead of time
of what the water storage capacity of
your soil is and whether you need to
invest in irrigation is an important
consideration okay so let's talk a
little bit about soil compaction on the
left you see a soil with good rooting
the roots extend both in the surface
layer as well as into subsoil in the
deeper layers that means that this plan
would have a lot of water and nutrients
available to it I also like to see you
know fairly dense booty patterns on the
right you see a soil that has multiple
compaction problems first it has may
have a crust on the surface which is
this often happens when the soil is
exposed to the elements especially the
raindrops and that reduces infiltration
and causes runoff and erosion problems
it may also have very tightly packed
crumbs so we've lost those large pores
that are essential for aeration and
water in transmission and also it limits
the routing so now we only have a few
roots and in this particular case we
additionally have a sub soil compaction
problem so the roots don't even go down
into the deeper layers and cannot access
the water and nutrients in those layers
so what are sort of the symptoms well
extended periods of saturation are often
a symptom of compaction you see that
here on the left if you have compacted
layer you have the water doesn't drain
standing water following a rain or
irrigation they all may be indicators of
plow layer compaction if the soil gets
tilt and of course you may only do this
at the establishment face but if you see
these big clods that's typically an
indication of a very compacted soil and
that's something that you want to want
to address just tilling it and and you
know say doing some primary tillage but
then say you know doing disking and
harrowing and pulverizing that soil
doesn't really address the problem
because soon enough that's Earl will
settle as you can see on the right here
it you know when once it gets wet it
will settle and it will become dense
animal heart and the roots will have
problems growing through okay so i
highly recommend doing some some upfront
work and do a little several a take a
shovel out or a pen at ramat or
something like that and and book and see
whether you have any of these problems
because some of the past management of
that particular field prior to
establishing the berry plants maybe may
have caused considerable compaction and
you first want to address that and
ameliorate you know just is a little bit
more information on that wanted to show
this to you this is actually part of a
video clip that I can't show because of
the limitation of the webinar technology
but there's two two important points one
that a root is a certain dimension and
especially the root tip and so you need
pores that are greater than point two
millimeters for a root tip to enter into
a poor and it's circle first needs to
wedge itself into that poor and then it
starts to push the particles in the
aggregates to the side and if that soil
is very hard
and it has a strength of greater than
300 psi then it has great difficulty
doing that so for roots to grow well you
need pores that are greater than point 2
millimeters and strength that is less
than 300 psi and typically what that
means is is a well or gated soil or a
naturally softer soil like a like a
sandy sandy loam or silt loam type soil
on the right here you see an example of
where this is a problem this big soil
Claude we see one root here that sort of
explored a little bit of that soil it
has some few fine root hairs but most of
that soil is basically not being
explored by the roots so the water and
nutrients that are in the rest of the
sort of volume are inaccessible to the
plan so that tends to cause more stress
for the plant
so what are some of the causes of plow
earlier compaction well basically a loss
of organic matter and thereby aggregate
stability mostly from intensive Tillett
so it so if this field has a legacy of
intensive tillage maybe you know
vegetable production or potatoes or
field crops and low organic matter
contents you're going to have some of
these type of problems also of course if
there's no bin bin no organic matter
addition so if there's not a history of
say manure application or compost and
you have great of potential for problems
if there's been a lot of traffic when
the Searle was wet lack of control
traffic so basically the entire field
was compacted and if we had a lot of
Cyril settling from so sir some of the
primary causes and you may want to look
at the history of that field to see
whether that was a problem so let's
briefly talk about sub soil compaction
sir now we're considering not the the
surface layer but really the compaction
that's deeper in the soil and it tends
to be a little bit more difficult to
address and it's also it's very
invisible you don't see the subsoil
unless you really make an effort than
you dig down to it also a lot of people
are not aware of the causes of that and
so if you are in a field that has say a
history of heavy traffic like manure
spreaders especially on wet soils you
may have a problem with sub soil
compaction Oh deeper the deeper layers
may have become very very dense because
the loads from this heavy equipment are
basically transferred deeper into the
soil and when that soil is wet it can
pack them this is especially a problem
if there's a poor weight distribution of
the equipment so some of the more modern
equipment have less of a problem but if
this field has a history of the kind of
stuff you see on the left here you
probably have a fairly serious subsoil
compaction in addition to having
compaction near the surface
if there's been a history with of
plowing because a lot of plowing occurs
with the wheel in the open furrow which
means that the subsoil is directly
compacted so it's definitely something
to look into would say a penetrator I'm
digging so it's important to consider
where the compaction is and these
penetra meters they're relatively
inexpensive tools it cost a little over
two hundred dollars sometimes you can
borrow them from an extension agent or a
certain water specialists are very
valuable tools and they are also an
integral part of our Cornell's oral
health test if you have that deep soil
compaction maybe some deep tillage is
needed deep-rooted cover crop maybe
needs to be established before you you
transplant your marries shallow
compaction requires the different
strategy than deep compaction and that's
why it's important measure where the
compaction is and we'll come back to
this in seminars later in the program
okay so we talked about the chemical the
physical and now let's discuss the soil
biology this is ed the component of the
soil that that that's still very much at
the frontier of science searles are
extremely complex and have very variable
conditions but we do know that most of
the biological activity occurs near the
surface the reason being that that's
where the most of the organic matter is
from basically often from the the plant
sources that k and the organic matter
decreases as we go further into soil and
thereby also the biological activity
decreases considerably
we often and we I mean fed magd off and
I and we co-authored a book that I'll
refer to a little bit later we'd like to
think in terms of organic matter as as
three general types Living Dead and very
dead I'll talk about each of those
individually but all three are very
important in terms of the functioning of
the soil and to produce high yields and
healthy crops so let's first start
talking about the the living part oh now
let's see there's a quick overview of
each of those I'm sorry I'm getting
ahead of myself so the living component
of the soil is what is a life in the
soil basically so these organisms they
play important roles in making nutrients
available suppressing disease producing
plant growth-promoting hormones creating
humans aggregating soils and it's
probably a few other things mentioned
another living component is planned
routes there also it's the below ground
part of the of the plants and they also
are typically very beneficial and of
course they're they're needed for the
plants to grow the dead part relates to
the recently dead organisms and crop
residues that provide basically the
energy and nutrients for the soil
organisms to live and function also
often call this active or particular
organic matter okay so this is the food
that sustains the system the third
component is basically the fraction of
the organic matter that's that's not as
active biologically has become very well
decomposed but that is really quite
recalcitrant and we often refer to that
as as humise or the kind of lock
material in soil but it's also very
beneficial primarily in terms of
supporting some of the physical and
chemical functions it has a high amounts
of negative charge so it allows it to
hold nutrients it allows us to hold
water and also stores a lot of the
carbon
let's look at each of those in a little
bit more detail so the living here and
you know we can we can teach an entire
course on this it's all those organisms
like bacteria fungi nematodes earthworms
might spring tails and moles and many
other organisms that are in the soil
that all play a very important role in
terms of the soil food web they all
interact in often very very complex ways
and then of course the plant roots as
you as you can see here on the left you
have the micro organisms on the right
here you have these like all critters
the colon ball Columbo's spiders mites
etc and then we might even have things
like Earth world or even you know macro
organisms like like moles that of course
also impact soil these organisms use the
resources in the soil that's where they
live a composed organic matter cycle
nutrients the influence plants and and
all the other biota they respond to
chemical and physical environment so if
you for example have a very compacted
soil unfavorable physical environment
you will have any you will have less
organisms and less diversity for example
if you have a soil like you see here in
the middle picture very compacted
exposed to the elements so therefore the
organisms have to deal with heat and
moisture extremes as opposed to a
situation here where we have compost on
the soil and soil is protected it's a
much more favorable environment if you
have say low pH or high pH that all
impacts these organisms but vice versa
these organizations also affect the
chemical and the physical environment
they can be beneficial for example if
you have a lot of plant roots or you
have a lot of organisms that that
decompose organic matter that creates
better aggregation
so better physical environment aeration
better water transmission etc so it goes
both ways the organisms respond to the
environment and they manipulate the
environment others there's some
organisms that are particularly
noteworthy one is the mycorrhizae and
they sir those are basically fungi and
with with extended hyphy as you can see
in this picture that in a way you can
think of as a symbiotic relationship
with plant roots that can extend the
plant roots into the soil and Allah and
basically facilitate better nutrient
acquisition and use so they enhance
nutrient uptake Oscars medicine assumin
micronutrients but especially phosphorus
is often very very much enhanced by
Michael rising they help with soil
aggregation form of defense against
pathogens tech plants against
phytotoxicity and enhance fitness in so
mycorrhizae eyes and especially in soils
that are not disturbed he very
beneficial another important concept is
that of suppressive soils and we often
have problems with certain diseases
Pythium phytophthora rhizoctonia etc and
if we create a healthy soil with lots of
organisms beneficial organisms like
Pseudomonas trichoderma they actually
provide an ability to suppress some of
these so borne pathogens basically by
eated a direct suppression or basically
by a larger abundance and sort of out
competing some of these pathogenic
organisms so having a rich soil often
can be very beneficial in terms using s
pressure so
management practices effects our life
well intensive tillett's reduces micro
Isaac colonization reduces diversity of
soil organisms so tillett's is often not
favorable for healthy soils organic
matter application is favorable it
increases diversity density and activity
of these organisms fertilizer
application affects the various
organisms it proliferates the growth of
fast-growing market organisms typically
more bacteria but reduces say fungi and
it reduces say nitrogen fixating
organisms as well an irrigation and
drainage of course affects the anaerobic
vs. aerobic organisms so we talked about
the living now a little bit about about
the dead organisms so that's basically
crop residues and dead plant roots and
all that and think of that as the food
that sustains these organisms in the
soil these are nutrients and energy that
help feed these organisms that are so
important so the soil food web which is
depicted here we're not talking about a
food chain but a more complex food web
where multiple organisms are involved in
the use of basically this organic matter
so it's the organic matter in the soil
that may be applied through manure or
compost or maybe dead roots or surface
material that basically feeds all these
other organisms bacteria fungi nematodes
that in turn affects all these other
organisms like protozoa arthropods and
so you kind of go up the food web and
the food chain but the important point
here is that if you don't supply this
organic matter if it's not there then
these organisms cannot thrive that's
what often is referred to as the bottom
OPP effect or the abundance of a
resource affects the abundance of its
consumers and think of it in terms of
the
human analogy if we did not feed
ourselves and get our energy and
nutrients we would not thrive either and
so it's just as important soil so the
very debt component then is the it is as
well d compost material you often see
that as sort of the lock part of the
soil the dark part and so it is very
important for water holding capacity but
also to retain cations and and so it
especially in a sandy soil increasing
the humours content allows for better
water and nutrient storage an important
point I think by now I think it's been
that that we have this interaction of
the physical the chemical and biological
so in the past because we focus so much
on the chemical we didn't have the all
these benefits of these interactions now
based on the discussions I'll give you
five seconds to think of any examples of
how each of these realms interact
I wished I could ask you how many of you
could come up with one or two or three
but here a number that that I that I
came up with and I've indicated that
blue is being a physical process green
being a biological process and yellow
being a chemical process so for example
hard soil and physical process reduces
routing acted soil suppresses beneficial
biological processes action also
increases root diseases and
denitrification both biological process
organic matter decomposition of
biological processes process increases
aggregation etc etc ok till it's in the
bottom here increases bacteria and
increases fungi so there's many ways in
which these interact and i think that
the point is that if you eat with our
past emphasis on the chemical part we've
often not given enough consideration for
these biological and physical components
so i think it become clear I think that
adding organic matter results in many
benefits and this is a depiction as
actually from a picture from Laurie
drink water in a horticulture department
all the benefits of adding organic
matter it increases biological activity
and composition luchief release
detoxifies harmful substances it
increases aggregation it promotes humise
and other growth promoting substances
includes pore structure improved soil
and Tails and water storage and all in
all healthier plants okay so this is
distinta general
um so a couple more points I wanted to
make is that is what has happened over
the past decades is that it's been a
different paradigm in in soil management
so in in the old days certainly in terms
of the natural ecosystems they evolved
with little disturbance they were either
forest or grassland or something like
that nutrients were recycled through
organic materials like leaves and animal
droppings the decomposing materials
would be feeding the soil it would be
nutrients and carbon and stimulated the
worst biological activity and then this
organic material was that mineralized by
all these organisms and that in turn
would feed the plants so so the plants
were in a way fed indirectly the
nutrients and the energy came from the
surface was processed by these organisms
and that in turn fed the plants in
modern agriculture with the onset of the
use of fertilizer we've started to
disturb the soil through a lot of
tillage and so we accelerated organic
matter mineralization and we have now
lower organic matter levels in the soils
and we use chemical fertilizers where we
basically feed the plant directly rather
than indirectly through the addition of
organic materials and so we've stopped
feeding all the soil organisms so we've
seen over the decades a very big
difference in terms of the ecology of
the soil and that's why the physical and
the biological processes and Miss
Orioles have become very compromised
because of those practices so few
important points inherent versus dynamic
soil quality ok so what we get the
natural soil versus how we manage we're
going to focus especially on this
dynamic soil health physical chemical
and biological and I think by now hope
you sort of appreciate the importance of
all of those components and they are
equally important a little bit about pre
and post establishment I'll talk about
that in the next
slides because that's an important
consideration from a management
perspective remember of the surface and
the subsoil are important and also we
have to think in terms of short-term and
long-term management a lot of the
chemical management is short term as a
constraint salo phosphorus levels we
apply fertilizer problem solved with
soil health we often have to look at a
more long-term approach so when it comes
to a very production most opportune time
for soil health improvement is typically
prior to planting stalling drain tiles
correcting sub soil fertility eh deep
ripping or other types of deep Taylor's
compost applications are cropping all
prior to establishment that's when you
have the opportunity to address a lot of
these constraints and keep in mind that
sub soil properties are not always that
visible or something any constraint that
you might have okay but they are
important for perennial crops and then
of course you still have opportunities
for post establishments oral health
management like for example continuous
supply of compost using mulches to
protect the soil promote good biological
activity sometimes we can use the intros
for say cover crops as you see in this
particular cases deserve grapevines so
we have to distinguish a little bit
between pre and post establishment so
this is my final slide dis some
reference material here's our the
website for the soil health program is
listed here and when you go there you
see at this point there's a lot of other
sites that that go with that you can
download the soil health training manual
which will refer to a later point in
time and if you're interested in broader
perspective on Cyril health management
this is a book that I co-authored with
Fred Magda from the University of
Vermont titled building soils for better
crops which is really about
sustainable soil management or Cyril
health management it's available from
the sustainable AG Network it can also
be downloaded as a PDF file from their
website and so with that Jeff I'll hand
it back to you alright thanks Harold and
this is where we enter our Q&A period
and I encourage you if you have any
questions to type them into the chat box
and we'll address them as they come
there were a few questions early on
Cathy asked the question what is soil
tilth a sorrel tilt it basically relates
to the kind of the aggregation structure
of the soil so I oil that has good soil
tails is not compacted it has these
aggregates and it typically if you
disturb the soil it doesn't come up as
clods but it comes up as nice friable
material that's maybe the best way to
characterize that I think of Cyril tails
to some extent as as aggregation
ok and a second question can a fragile
pan layer be fixed by subsoil that's a
good question a yes you can you can
initially you know depending on the
depth of the of the fragile pan layer if
it's very deep would say you know two
and a half feet then it's difficult to
get down that far but if it's a shallow
a layer you can but they do tend to
reform so it's if you were considering
establishing Barry's honest on a fragile
and soil I would definitely do that
tillage the deep tillage but they do
tend to reestablish over a longer time
period and I'm talking more about maybe
eight to ten or years thanks Harold I
have a question of my own you talked
about surface compaction versus
compaction than in the deeper layers and
now there's you know a lot of discussion
about the use of cover crops to deal
with compaction issues can you comment
on cover cropping use for compaction
modification yes so um you know when we
think about cover crops we we have to
have to consider what really our
objective is with the use of cover crops
so if we have a compaction problem near
the surface we might want to use a very
dense and fibrous cover crop like a like
rye grass or something like that if we
have a compaction deeper in the soil we
want to get one to use a cover crop that
has strong roots that go deeper into the
soil for example alfalfa roots do that
there's a lot of interest in using save
radishes that that very aggressively
grow deeper into the soil as well so so
when it comes to to cover cropping you
really have to think about what's your
primary objective is and your compaction
relief is only one of several you may
also want to consider adding nitrogen or
you want to use a cover crop so you get
some mulch so like for example the
picture that I showed of the of the
vineyard that had that had why rowing in
the Indian two rows they use that then
to they cut that and they use that to
spread that over over the over the
sorrel service so you have all these
different objectives with with cover
crops which is you know an interesting
point in and by itself if you're
interested in in using cover crop there
there is a great publication and i
believe it's titled managing cover crops
profitably it's also published by the
sustainable AG network and know many of
you are probably familiar with it for
those of you who are not that is really
an outstanding publication and it it it
addresses the management of cover crops
from the perspective of what your
objectives are you know nitrogen
management compaction relief service
cover etc so that's I'm sorry Jeff
that's a bit of a little bit of a
long-winded answer but you know there's
cover crops and there's cover crop shin
you want to make sure that you select
the right one for the problem that
you're trying to address well thank you
very much and I think Tom derkman also
has a web-based tool that does a pretty
good job of describing the attributes of
different cover crops right Kathy in the
meantime had a comment or question
related to subsoil and its use for crops
like strawberries or raspberries that
have maybe a shorter shorter time frame
than something like blueberries um can
you come yeah yeah perhaps i'm somewhat
misrepresented this in that there's uh
there's various components to it when
you when you think about substituting to
overcome a frangipane then you you do
allow those woods to move into that
friday pan and even though the friday
pan may somewhat established once the
roots are in there they are they
basically and so the sub soiling is is
always beneficial even though you know
with blueberries maybe you're looking at
a much longer time horizon it's it's
those first years that are most critical
so that you can get those roots down
there oh I think it's in almost all
cases it's it's beneficial do the
subsoil if you have a fry Japan
thank you I have an additional question
you mentioned a couple situations
tillage was one of them where you're
favoring bacteria / fungi you also
mention that the use of fertilizer does
the same thing this does developing a
cover crop actually work in the opposite
direction of boosting the fungi
population yes it tends to especially if
you don't do a lot of disturbance you
know I when we talk about cover crops
one thing you try to prevent doing a lot
of tillage do is establish a cover crop
so you'd like to do it with with
equipment that you know like a no-till
drill or something like that I think
with very production of course you don't
do much tillage maybe only early on but
I think what's critical is to think
about the history of that site so if
there's been a lot of postulates then
that it has impacted bacteria forces
fungi bacteria being more common with
with intensively tilt and fertilize
field and you know when you have say
very production you would like to like
to see your more fungi because of the
the benefits that it provides it will of
course change over time because once you
establish your field and your your your
berries you will you won't do much
intensive tillage and if you manage well
and you supply organic materials you
will see a gradual change in the biology
of that soil
I'm waiting to see if an has a question
here and has a long question I can see
it's more of a comment for everyone else
yeah yeah um and this is putting you on
the spot but you know that there are a
number of companies that sell products I
guess you would call them soil
amendments or plan enhancing products
and it's unfair to ask this question but
you've talked about the biology of the
soil and how important it is geez do you
see any research that shows benefits of
some of these products in terms of
products that are that are you know more
commercial products that are sold that
maybe like the regional national level
no you know not very much I mean you
know the if it is soil is low in
inorganic matter content there are a
number of ways to address that you know
say compost sometimes if you have manure
that's available say from a nearby dairy
farm or some other livestock farm that
can be very beneficial well products
that are more commercially sold some
humic acids are sold I haven't seen any
research really that supports that in in
a very significant way and and i would
say i would want to compare that with
say you know a compost application you
sometimes hear about remineralizing
soils we mineralizing it's a kind of a
different difficult word where we're
basically that's more geologic material
is being added that will only be you can
only justify that if you really do have
deficiencies in in some of these plant
nutrients a lot of times it's it's much
easier to address that with fertilizer
if you're ganic producer and that's not
an option you really want to do some
soil testing first and see whether those
those elements are really limiting
before you buy something like
mm-hmm and in the meantime Verne has a
question are there practical ways to
optimize mycorrhizae and very plantings
other than avoiding high p and tillage
Verne I think that this is a I'm getting
on thin ice here it's a little bit
beyond my expertise when it comes to
bury plantings typically having a
healthy soil with biology will basically
favor the development of my crazy in a
system that's that's not disturbed
basically once you have it established I
believe there are inoculants being sold
but I you know I'd really have to find
out actually I'm not an expert on that
perhaps some other people that are in
here maybe Marvin Ritz me knows that
people who have a little bit more
management experience with this burn
perhaps you know you know yourself I
know Marvin is typing right now
and while we're waiting for them to
respond I think we'll switch to the last
screen that we have for you to view
today and encourage you all to attend
future meetings that we're having coming
up here and if you haven't already
filled out the demographics or the
pretest please do so and and I can see
that Marvins response is here not aware
of any strong data and indicating that
these inoculants work especially in
healthy soils I do want to thank our
presenter Harold vanness thank you very
much Harold and welcome pleasure and I
want to tell you that the next portion
of this series is next week on october
fourteenth from 2 to 3 15 in the
afternoon it will be Janet Fallon she'll
be talking to us about soil sampling
procedures and soil testing with that
we're going to be signing off
I will mention this one last comment
here from Glenn Kohler and he's talking
about perennial crops such as fruit
trees general guideline about balancing
between use of inorganic versus composts
as a source for soil nutrient management
thank you very much Glenn all right and
with that I'm going to end the session I
do want to say too I'm going to leave
this open so that you can download both
the demographics and the pretest take
the time to do that and or if you want
to check out the web links link up to
them save them for future reference and
I hope to see you next week thank you
very much
you
Jeff and Harold I want to thank you both
you did a great job
you
you hear me Cassie yes okay I I sorry i
had already logged off and that's a bad
somebody outside or but yeah I it go
well did it I I know I was a little
concerned that I was a little rushed or
um or was it not that case no I thought
it was great and I took tons of notes so
there was funny there was plenty of time
to think about things and whatever okay
excellent excellent good thank you so
much I hope it set the states for all
all those other webinars that are going
to be following absolutely absolutely
right Jeff if you're talking to us we
can't hear you for some reason
you
okay i'm i am i'm gonna log off then
alright thanks so much Harold thanks a
lot yep I'm glad it went well it was it
was fantastic great thank you
Jeff I still can't hear you are you
there oh yeah I was answering your
question from room d oh ok hey yeah went
pretty well Harold did a great job yeah
it went fantastic absolutely right so
all the bases were covered then
absolutely I didn't forget anything I
guess is my question nope I don't
believe so